This Christmas, Luke was in Iraq with a sniper unit in the Marines on a little forward operating base in Ramadi, maybe 200 guys-- bunk beds, dirt floors, pretty basic. They'd go out for two days at a time, set up a covert position in a house or a building, with a long range rifle, monitor what was going on in the street, shoot at guys who were setting up bombs in the road.
这个圣诞节，卢克和海军陆战队的一个狙击小组待在伊拉克拉马迪的一个小型前沿作战基地里，大约200人——上下铺，泥土地面，条件相当简陋。他们每次出任务两天，在一个房子或建筑物里架设隐蔽点，用远程步枪监视街上的动静，射击那些在路上安放炸弹的人。
The people we encountered, mostly I don't think they were really well-trained. And if we're doing our job right, they don't necessarily know where they're getting shot at from. So that makes it harder for them to turn around and return fire.
我们遇到的人，大部分我觉得他们并没有受过很好的训练。如果我们工作做得对，他们甚至不知道自己是从哪里被击中的。所以这让他们很难转身还击。
Spending hour after hour on watch, his is like the military cliche-- lots of extended boredom, broken up by moments of great intensity.
在值班时消磨掉一小时又一小时，他的经历就像军事老套路——大量漫长的无聊，被偶尔极其紧张的时刻所打断。
And then you're constantly trying to then stay sharp and pay-- you know. It might be boring. There might not be anything going on, but you sort of have to stay-- try and keep focused and stay vigilant and sort of think your way into it not being boring and having your brain turned on.
然后你得一直努力保持敏锐，注意——你知道的。也许很无聊。可能什么事都没有，但你必须保持——试着保持专注，保持警惕，并试着通过思考来让自己不觉得无聊，让大脑保持运转。
Men, these tough guys, Marine snipers, will come off duty, go back to their base. There wasn't much entertainment, not the greatest internet back then. This is 2005. So they watched DVDs, specifically this.
男人们，这些硬汉，海军陆战队的狙击手们，下哨回到基地。那里没什么娱乐活动，那时的网速也不怎么样。那是2005年。所以他们看DVD，特别是这个。
Well, I believe three minutes is plenty of time for some coffee.
好吧，我相信三分钟冲杯咖啡足够了。
Yes, coffee, please!
是的，咖啡，谢谢！
Hey, we're dying. Load us up.
嘿，我们要死了。给我们来点。
It isn't ready yet.
还没准备好。
What?
什么？
Mommy.
妈咪。
What do you mean it's not ready? It's 6:00 in the morning. Nothing says coffee like 6:00 in the morning.
你说没准备好是什么意思？现在是早上6点。没有什么比早上6点喝咖啡更合适的了。
And what is this?
这是什么？
That's the Gilmore Girls.
那是《吉尔莫女孩》。
Yeah, the Gilmore Girls, the story of single mom Lorelai Gilmore, her teenage daughter Rory, her mom Emily, and the small town they live in, fictional Stars Hollow, Connecticut, beloved by a generation of tween girls and their mothers-- and other people too.
是的，《吉尔莫女孩》，讲述单身母亲罗蕾莱·吉尔莫、她十几岁的女儿罗里、她的母亲艾米丽，以及她们居住的小镇——虚构的康涅狄格州星谷，被一代青春期女孩和她们的母亲所钟爱——当然还有其他人。
It's a very girly show.
这是一部非常女孩气的剧。
It's a girly show. The girl is right there in the title, sure.
这是一部女孩气的剧。标题里就有“女孩”，当然。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I mean, there are a lot of scenes of like, you know, a mom and her daughter talking about how they're obsessed with coffee.
我是说，剧里有很多场景，你知道的，妈妈和女儿谈论她们对咖啡有多痴迷。
Yeah. I mean, I'm of two minds on how girly it is. I mean, I think that's part of what we liked about it too. Because there were zero women around where we were, and also because I think my platoon, my friends, we sort of liked doing things that were different and weirding people out a little bit.
是啊。我是说，对于它有多“女孩气”，我有两种想法。我是说，我觉得这也是我们喜欢它的原因之一。因为我们周围根本没有女性，而且我觉得我的排、我的朋友们，我们有点喜欢做些与众不同的事，让别人觉得有点怪怪的。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
You know, and it would sort of bother the crusty old first sergeant who was always yelling at us about things and making our lives miserable. It would sort of bother him if we were watching a girly show or if you wore a pink t-shirt to a company event, things like that. But he couldn't yell at you like you were doing something incorrectly like he could everything else. So it was almost like a little bit of a rebellion that the sniper platoon was all holed up watching Gilmore Girls.
你知道，这会让那个总是对我们大吼大叫、让我们生活痛苦的古板老军士长感到困扰。如果我们在看一部女孩气的剧，或者在公司活动时穿粉色T恤之类的，他会很困扰。但他又不能像指责其他事情那样指责我们做得不对。所以，狙击排全窝在一起看《吉尔莫女孩》，这简直像是一种小小的反叛。
Here's a typical scene. It's about being a mom and being a daughter. Lorelai, who's the single mom on the show, is being criticized by her mother about the way that she's raising her daughter, Rory.
这是一个典型片段。关于做母亲和做女儿。剧中单亲妈妈罗蕾莱，正被她母亲批评她抚养女儿罗里的方式。
Lorelai Gilmore, I've watched you do a lot of stupid things in your life, and I have held my tongue.
罗蕾莱·吉尔莫，我看着你这辈子做了不少蠢事，我一直忍着没说。
Ha, you've what?
哈，你做了什么？
But I will not stand by and let you allow that girl to ruin her life.
但我绝不会袖手旁观，让你任由那女孩毁掉自己的人生。
Mom, back off.
妈，离远点。
She spent the night out with that boy, the one you let her run off to that dance with.
她和那个男孩在外过夜，那个你让她私奔去跳舞的男孩。
Mom, so help me god, I will not get into this with you.
妈，看在上帝的份上，我不会跟你争这个。
She's doing the same thing you did.
她在走你的老路。
No, she's not.
不，她没有。
She's going to get pregnant.
她会怀孕的。
No, she's not.
不，她不会。
She's going to ruin everything just like you ruined everything.
她会把一切都毁了，就像你毁了一切一样。
No, she's not! No, she's not! No, she's not! Rory is a good kid, Mom. She's not me.
不，她不会！不，她不会！不，她不会！罗里是个好孩子，妈。她不是我。
What kind of mother are you?
你是个什么样的母亲？
So yeah, Marine, what do you see?
所以，海军陆战队员，你看到了什么？
Yeah, I mean, it is girly. And there's a lot of women talking. And I know there's the whole scale. Like, two women can't talk on screen, like men won't watch the show. There has to be a man or they're talking about a man. Yeah, it's girly, but it's also a funny show. It's a smart show. It's a well-written show.
是啊，我的意思是，它确实很女孩气。而且里面有很多女人在说话。我知道有个不成文的规矩：如果有两个女人在屏幕上说话，男人们就不会看这部剧。除非有个男人，或者她们在谈论一个男人。没错，它是很女孩气，但它也是一部有趣的剧。它很聪明。剧本写得很好。
I think first, it's good. And I don't think we would have watched it if it wasn't good, the same reason everyone else watched it. But I think it struck a particular chord with us as sort of escapism, a different world from where we were.
我觉得首先，它很好看。我不认为如果它不好看我们会去看，原因和其他人看的原因一样。但我认为它作为一种逃避现实的方式，某种远离我们所在世界的不同世界，与我们产生了特别的共鸣。
Yeah, yeah. It's hard to imagine like a world further away from a war zone in Ramadi.
是啊，是啊。很难想象一个比拉马迪战区更遥远的世界。
Right. Yeah. It's a really idyllic kind of world, but it's not super sappy. It still has sarcasm and weirdness that makes the idyllic part of it-- the really nice warm part of it-- it sort of makes it even more palatable and real maybe.
没错。是啊。那是一个非常田园诗般的世界，但它又不是超级多愁善感。它依然有那种讽刺和怪诞，让田园部分——那非常美好温暖的部分——变得更容易让人接受，甚至更真实。
Luke says they all learned about the Gilmore Girls from their corpsman Jess, whose sister watched the show and got hooked himself after he noticed a Tom Waits reference in one episode. He's into Tom Waits. A few of the guys started watching. Other guys who complained that it was on, and then they reluctantly get pulled in themselves until they had a core group-- Jess, Erik, John, Greg, seven or eight guys in all-- who watched everything.
卢克说他们都是从卫生兵杰斯那里了解到《吉尔莫女孩》的，杰斯的妹妹看这部剧，而杰斯在注意到其中一集提到汤姆·威茨后自己也入坑了。他喜欢汤姆·威茨。几个家伙开始看。其他抱怨的人后来也勉强加入了，直到他们形成了一个核心小组——杰斯、埃里克、约翰、格雷格，总共七八个人——他们看了每一集。
Hey, where were you and your friends on the show's big controversies? Like Rory had three guys over the course of the different seasons. There was Jess. There was Logan. And there was Dean. And for people who haven't seen the show, it's sort of like Jess was the rebel. Logan was the rich kid. And Dean was the townie, maybe a little boring.
嘿，对于剧里的大争议，你和你的朋友们站在哪一边？比如罗里在不同季节里有三个男人。有杰斯。有洛根。还有迪恩。对于没看过这部剧的人来说，杰斯是叛逆者。洛根是富家子弟。迪恩是小镇男孩，可能有点无聊。
Right.
没错。
Who did you guys side with?
你们站在哪一边？
So Erik was a big Dean supporter. There was a lot of-- like sort of a running gag of Erik coming to Dean's defense and us making fun of him for it.
埃里克是迪恩的忠实支持者。当时有个梗，就是埃里克总是为迪恩辩护，我们以此取笑他。
Well, Dean was married. I mean, Dean was married.
可是，迪恩结婚了。我的意思是，迪恩已经结婚了。
I think Erik would say that they were always true love, and the marriage doesn't count.
我想埃里克会说那是真爱，婚姻不算数。
Mhm. OK. And you, who were you with?
嗯。好的。那你呢，你支持谁？
I'm anti-Dean, and I'm kind of OK with Jess and Logan.
我反迪恩，我对杰斯和洛根还算支持。
I'm with you. I never had a problem with Logan. I think Logan was really-- he was so into her.
我跟你一样。我从没觉得洛根有什么问题。我觉得洛根真的很——他真的很爱她。
Yeah, he was good to her. And I think he was really-- she sort of needed--
是啊，他对她很好。而且我觉得他真的——她确实需要——
OK, we don't need to play any more of this part of the interview on the radio. You get the idea. They were real, actual fans. And probably this is a good time to out myself, if you haven't picked this up already. I have seen all the old episodes myself, though not the new recent Gilmore Girls reboot reunion shows.
好了，我们不需要在广播里播放采访的这一部分了。你们明白意思了。他们是真实的、真正的粉丝。如果你们还没看出来，现在大概是我自曝身份的好时机。我自己也看过所有旧剧集，不过最近重启的《吉尔莫女孩》重聚节目没看过。
I have lots of opinions about the show, I should say, that Luke did not share. For instance, there's a whole host of cartoonishly wacky B plot townspeople characters I was not into.
我必须说，我对这部剧有很多看法，卢克并没有分享这些看法。例如，剧里有一大堆漫画式的古怪配角，我就不太喜欢。
You hate Kirk?
你讨厌柯克？
I hated Kirk.
我讨厌柯克。
Oh, Ira.
哦，艾拉。
I also believe the Gilmore Girls has the worst music cues of any series in the last three decades of television. Case in point.
我还认为《吉尔莫女孩》是过去三十年里所有电视剧中音乐配乐最差的一部。举个例子。
[MUSIC - SAM PHILIPS, "LA LA"]
[音乐 - 山姆·菲利普斯，《啦啦》]
I think the cues that you're talking about, like the la la la stuff, I mean, I think we sang that, you know, walking around. Well, like, (SINGING) La la la la la la la.
我觉得你说的那些配乐，就是那些“啦啦啦”的东西，我是说，我想我们走路的时候也会唱。就像，（唱歌）啦啦啦啦啦啦啦。
But that's not what we're here to talk about. I'm telling you this story because, of course, it's Christmas, and this is a Christmas story. Back in 2005, when they were in Ramadi, as Christmas approached, they were far from home, missing family and life there. Luke decided to go online.
但那不是我们今天要谈的。我讲这个故事是因为，当然，现在是圣诞节，这是一个圣诞故事。回到2005年，当他们在拉马迪时，圣诞节临近，他们远离家乡，想念家人和那里的生活。卢克决定上网看看。
I was going to try and buy-- and I thought it would be a fun and funny gift to try and buy guys Gilmore Girls t-shirts or something as a Christmas present. And the Gilmore Girls website store at the time, all the clothing was either like a spaghetti strap tank top or a baby doll tee.
我想买——我觉得给伙伴们买《吉尔莫女孩》的T恤或者之类的作为圣诞礼物会既好玩又有趣。但当时《吉尔莫女孩》的网站商店里，所有衣服要么是细肩带背心，要么是娃娃衫。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
There was not any unisex or male anything on there.
上面没有任何中性或男性的东西。
And you guys were bad asses. But you weren't going to go that far.
而你们是硬汉。但你们不会走那么远。
Yeah, well, I mean, it's not flattering.
是啊，我是说，那并不讨好。
Yeah. [LAUGHS]
是啊。[笑声]
And so he wrote a letter to the creator of Gilmore Girls, Amy Sherman-Palladino. Here's a bit of it.
所以他给《吉尔莫女孩》的创作者艾米·谢尔曼-帕拉迪诺写了一封信。这里有一部分。
"I have to tell you, my guys and I absolutely love your show. I know you must hear that all the time. I even read a recent endorsement of the show in Esquire magazine. Still, I'd venture to say that we are even further outside the Gilmore Girls target audience. I live in a strict, macho sometimes violent world that very often does not make sense. Stars Hollow, the small town where the Gilmore Girls takes place--"
“我必须告诉你，我和我的伙伴们绝对喜欢你的剧。我知道你肯定经常听到这些。我甚至在《时尚先生》杂志上看到过对该剧的最近一次推荐。不过，我敢说我们甚至比《吉尔莫女孩》的目标受众还要遥远。我生活在一个严格、大男子主义、有时暴力的世界里，这个世界经常让人无法理解。星谷，那个《吉尔莫女孩》发生的小镇——”
Wait, wait, you explained to Amy Sherman-Palladino what Stars Hollow was in your letter? [LAUGHS]
等等，等等，你在信里给艾米·谢尔曼-帕拉迪诺解释星谷是什么？[笑声]
Being reunited with the reality of this letter 10 years later has really disabused me of a lot of my illusions. Because I remembered the really good parts, and I thought I must of wrote a great letter. And then reading it again, I see like, oh man. This was not all good.
10年后重温这封信的现实，真的打碎了我许多幻想。因为我记得那些特别好的部分，以为自己写了一封很棒的信。然后再读一遍，我发现，天哪。这并不全是好的。
The rest of the letter actually is pretty good, a really nice summary of what he and his guys like so much about the TV show. And then at the bottom, there's a PS. "PS," he writes--
信的其余部分其实很不错，很好地总结了他和他的伙伴们为什么那么喜欢这部剧。在底部，有一个附言。“附言，”他写道——
"I checked the website, and the shirts appear to be cut for girls. What gives? I was going to buy the guys Christmas presents."
“我看了网站，衬衫似乎是为女孩剪裁的。怎么回事？我本来打算买给伙伴们当圣诞礼物的。”
Which, I have to say, was handled perfectly, just enough of a hint. A few weeks later, sure enough, packages arrive-- five big boxes.
不得不说，这件事处理得很完美，暗示得恰到好处。几周后，果然，包裹送到了——五个大箱子。
And we opened them up, and they were full of these like navy blue wool jackets that had very subtle teal embroidering on the breast that said Gilmore Girls in the typeface and a really nice letter from Amy Sherman-Palladino.
我们打开一看，里面装满了那种深蓝色的羊毛夹克，胸前有非常精致的青色刺绣，用那种字体写着《吉尔莫女孩》，还有艾米·谢尔曼-帕拉迪诺写的一封非常友好的信。
These were crew jackets, made as gifts for the show's camera people and gaffers in men's sizes.
这些是工作夹克，是作为礼物为剧组的摄像师和电工制作的男款尺码。
It was a big morale boost for everybody. I remember taking them back and giving them out and sort of reading the letter. And even guys that didn't watch the show were excited.
这对每个人的士气都是极大的鼓舞。我记得把它们带回去分发，还读了那封信。即使是没看过剧的伙伴们也很兴奋。
Obviously the show meant a lot to my friends and I. I think I tried to tell her that she let us feel like it was ours a little bit.
显然这部剧对我和我的朋友们意义重大。我想我试图告诉她，她让我们觉得这部剧也稍微属于我们了。
Are you choking up?
你哽咽了吗？
Yeah. Yeah. I just think it was really generous of her.
是啊。是啊。我觉得她真的非常慷慨。
It really felt like Christmas morning, he told me. The jackets were just what he wanted, even though he didn't even know that jackets like this existed. I wonder if it felt that way to Amy Sherman-Palladino also. You know? The letter Luke wrote to her, like a present she didn't even know she wanted, didn't even know she could want till it arrived. And then she was really happy about it.
他告诉我，这感觉真的就像圣诞节的早晨。这些夹克正是他想要的，尽管他甚至不知道还有这种夹克存在。我不知道对艾米·谢尔曼-帕拉迪诺来说是否也有同样的感觉。你知道吗？卢克写给她的信，就像一份她甚至不知道自己想要、甚至不知道自己能想要的礼物，直到它送达。然后她真的为此感到很高兴。
She's told people that she's kept Luke's letter in her desk all these years. It's been over a decade now. Well, today on our program, with the holidays happening, we have stories of people wanting stuff, daring to want stuff-- really, really feeling it. But getting the thing that you want can feel so much different than what you imagined. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Our show today in two acts-- Zoe Chace coming up in the second. Stay with us.
她告诉别人，这些年来她一直把卢克的信放在桌子上。到现在已经过去十多年了。嗯，今天在我们的节目中，随着节日的到来，我们有关于人们想要东西、敢于想要东西的故事——真正地、深刻地感受着。但得到你想要的东西，感觉可能和你想象的截然不同。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目分为两幕——佐伊·蔡斯将在第二幕登场。留下来。
Act One, Lopsided Tannenbaum. Let's begin today with this Christmas story. It's a piece fiction read by the author, Maile Meloy.
第一幕，倾斜的圣诞树。让我们从这个圣诞故事开始。这是作者梅莉·梅洛伊朗读的一篇小说。
Everett thought it was a good tree. His four-year-old daughter agreed. His wife said it was lopsided and looked like a bush. It was a tall Douglas fir, bare on one side where it had crowded out its neighbor. The branchless side could go against the living room wall. The bushy side was for decorations.
埃弗雷特觉得这是一棵好树。他四岁的女儿表示同意。他妻子说它长歪了，看起来像个灌木丛。这是一棵高大的道格拉斯冷杉，靠邻居的那一面光秃秃的。没有树枝的那一面可以靠着客厅的墙。茂密的那一面用于装饰。
Everett dragged it through the snow by the trunk, and his daughter, Anne Marie clung to the upper branches and rode on her stomach. Pam, his wife, followed with an armload of pine boughs and juniper branches. She seemed to have decided not to say anything more about the tree, which was fine with Everett.
埃弗雷特拖着树干穿过积雪，他的女儿安妮·玛丽紧紧抓住上面的树枝，趴在上面。他的妻子帕姆带着一捧松枝和杜松枝跟在后面。她似乎决定不再对这棵树发表任何意见，这正合埃弗雷特的心意。
The Jimmy was parked where the trail split off in the logging road, and Everett opened the back to throw the tools and boughs in, then rope the tree to the roof with nylon cords. Pam brushed off Anne Marie's snowsuit and buckled her in the front so she wouldn't get carsick. The smell of pine and juniper filled the car as they drove down the mountain.
吉米车停在小路和伐木路的分岔处，埃弗雷特打开后备箱把工具和树枝扔进去，然后用尼龙绳把树捆在车顶上。帕姆帮安妮·玛丽刷掉滑雪服上的雪，把她系在副驾驶座上，以免她晕车。当他们开车下山时，车里弥漫着松树和杜松的香味。
Everett sang "chestnut's roasting on an open fire" in his best lounge singer croon. "With Jack Frost nipping at your nose," he reached over and nipped at Anne Marie's and she squealed. He stopped, forgetting the words. Pam prompted-- "Yuletide carols," half singing, shy about her voice. Everett picked it up again with, "being sung by a choir."
埃弗雷特用他最好的休息室歌手的声音哼唱着《栗子在火上烤》。“当杰克·弗罗斯特咬你的鼻子时，”他伸出手捏了捏安妮·玛丽的鼻子，她尖叫起来。他停了下来，忘了词。帕姆提示道——“圣诞颂歌，”半唱着，对自己的声音感到害羞。埃弗雷特接着唱道，“正在由合唱团歌唱。”
That was when they saw the couple at the side of the road-- "folks dressed up like Eskimos." Everett thought for a second that he had conjured them up with his song. The man wore a blue parka and held up a broken crosscountry ski. The woman wore red gaiters over wool trousers, a man's peacoat, and a fur hat. They waved. Everett slowed to a stop and roll down the window.
就在那时，他们看到了路边的这对夫妇——“穿着像爱斯基摩人一样的人。”埃弗雷特有一秒钟以为是他的歌把他们召唤出来的。那个男人穿着蓝色派克大衣，举着一根断了的越野滑雪杖。女人穿着毛线裤外的红色绑腿，男式短大衣，戴着皮帽。他们挥手。埃弗雷特减速停下，摇下车窗。
"Nice day for a ski," he said. "It was," the man said. He was about Everett's height and age, not yet pushing 40, with a day or two of bristle on his chin.
“滑雪的好日子，”他说。“曾经是，”那男人说。他大约和埃弗雷特身高和年龄相当，还没到40岁，下巴上有几天的胡茬。
"I broke a ski and we're lost," the woman began. "We're not lost," the man said. "We are completely lost," the woman said.
“我折断了滑雪杖，我们迷路了，”女人开始说。“我们没迷路，”男人说。“我们完全迷路了，”女人说。
She was younger than the man, with high, pink cheekbones in the cold. Everett felt friendly and warm from the tree and the singing. "Your car must be close," he said, "you're on the road." "The car is on a different road," the woman said. "Well, we'll find it," Everett said.
她比那个男人年轻，在寒冷中有着粉红色的高颧骨。因为这棵树和刚才的歌声，埃弗雷特感到友好而温暖。“你们的车一定很近，”他说，“你们在路上。”“车在另一条路上，”女人说。“好吧，我们会找到的，”埃弗雷特说。
In the rear view mirror, he saw Pam's eyes widen at him from the backseat. Pam was slight and dark-haired and accused him of favoring the kind of blonde who held sorority car washes. It was a joke, but it was partly true.
在后视镜里，他看到帕姆在后座上对他瞪大了眼睛。帕姆身材娇小，深色头发，总是指责他偏爱那种会举办联谊会洗车活动的金发女郎。这只是个玩笑，但部分是真实的。
With a bucket and sponge, this hitchhiker would fit right in. Everett got out of the car and untied a nylon cord to open the back hatch. His wife had sleds and jackets in the back seat with her, and he thought she would want some separation of family and hitchhikers. She wouldn't look at him now.
带着水桶和海绵，这个搭车客会很合适。埃弗雷特下了车，解开一根尼龙绳打开后舱。他妻子后座有雪橇和夹克，他以为她会希望把家人和搭车客隔开。她现在不看他。
"You'll have to sit with the juniper boughs," he told the couple. "Better than freezing in a snowbank," the blonde said, climbing into the way back. Even in the wool pants, she had a sweet figure, of the car soaping type. "We really appreciate this," the man said.
“你们得坐在杜松枝上，”他告诉这对夫妇。“比冻在雪堆里好，”那个金发女郎说着，爬进后面。即使穿着羊毛裤，她也有个甜美的身材，是那种适合洗车的类型。“我们真的很感激，”男人说。
Everett shut them all in, lashed on the skis, and tied the tree down. It made no sense for Pam to be angry. This wasn't country where you left people in the snow. The man looked strong, but not too strong. Everett could take him if he needed to.
埃弗雷特关上车门，绑好滑雪板，系紧树。帕姆生气是没道理的。这又不是那种会把人丢在雪地里的地方。男人看起来很壮，但不是特别壮。必要时，埃弗雷特能对付他。
Back in the driver's seat, he pulled onto the road as snow fell in clumps off the big pine the couple had stood under. His daughter turned around in her seat as well as she could with her seat belt on and announced to the new passengers, "We have a CB radio."
回到驾驶座，他驶入公路，雪从这对夫妇站立的那棵大松树上簌簌落下。他女儿在座位上尽可能地转过身，向新乘客宣布：“我们有CB无线电。”
"A CB?" the man in the parka said, "what's your handle?" Anne Marie looked confused. "Your name," Everett explained, "on the radio."
“CB？”穿派克大衣的男人说，“你的代号是什么？”安妮·玛丽看起来很困惑。“你的名字，”埃弗雷特解释道，“在无线电上的。”
"Batgirl," Anne Marie told the strangers, her cheeks flushing. "You've got a handle?" Everett asked the hitchhikers in back. "I'm Clyde," the man said. "Bonnie," the woman said. Everyone was silent for a moment.
“蝙蝠女孩，”安妮·玛丽告诉陌生人，脸颊发红。“你们有代号吗？”埃弗雷特问后面的搭车客。“我是克莱德，”男人说。“邦妮，”女人说。每个人沉默了片刻。
"That's really funny," Everett finally said. Though between his shoulder blades, he felt a prick of worry. "You must have a CB too." "No, those are our names," the man said.
“真好笑，”埃弗雷特最终说道。虽然在肩胛骨之间，他感到一阵担忧。“你们一定也有CB。”“不，那是我们的名字，”男人说。
The CB crackled on. "What's this Continental Divide?" a man's voice asked. Everett picked up the handset still thinking about Bonnie and Clyde. "You mean, what is it?" "Yeah," the voice said.
CB无线电吱吱作响。“什么是大陆分水岭？”一个男人的声音问。埃弗雷特拿起听筒，还在想邦妮和克莱德的事。“你是说，它是什么？”“是啊，”那个声音说。
So Everett explained that the snow and rain on the west side of the mountains ran to the Pacific. And the water on the east side ran to the Gulf of Mexico. "I never heard of such a thing," the voice said. "That's what it is," Everett said. He thought of something, the recruiting of a witness.
于是埃弗雷特解释说，山脉西侧的雪和雨会流向太平洋。东侧的水流向墨西哥湾。“我从没听说过这种事，”那个声音说。“这就是它，”埃弗雷特说。他想到了什么，寻找证人。
"We just picked up some hitchhikers named Bonnie and Clyde," he said. "How about that?" A wheezing laugh came over the radio. "No kidding?" the voice asked. "You watch your back then. So long."
“我们刚接了两个搭车客，叫邦妮和克莱德，”他说。“怎么样？”无线电里传来一阵喘息般的笑声。“没开玩笑吧？”那个声音问。“那你小心点。再见。”
Everett hung up the handset. "So," he said to his passengers, as if he hadn't just acted out of fear of them, "whereas your stolen jalopy?" "We parked by Fire Creek," Clyde said. Everett could tell he wasn't from Montana. If he'd been from Montana, he would have said "crick." "You didn't get far," he said. "No," Bonnie said. "How'd you break the ski?" Bonnie and Clyde both fell silent.
埃弗雷特挂上听筒。“那么，”他对着乘客说，就好像他刚才没有因为害怕他们而采取行动，“你们被偷的旧车在哪？”“我们停在火溪边，”克莱德说。埃弗雷特看得出他不是蒙大拿人。如果是蒙大拿人，他会说“crick”。“你们没走多远，”他说。“没有，”邦妮说。“你们怎么弄断滑雪杖的？”邦妮和克莱德都沉默了。
Everett drove. The windows were iced from everyone's breathing, and he turned up the defroster. The fans seemed very loud. He took the road Fire Creek. "This is it," he said stopping the Jimmy. There was a place at the trail had to park cars, but there were no cars, just snow and trees and the creek running under the ice. Everett didn't look back at his life. He scanned the empty turn out and hoped this was not one of those times you looked back on and wished he had done one thing different, though it seem perfectly natural to do what you did at the time.
埃弗雷特开车。窗户因为呼吸而结了冰，他调高了除霜器。风扇声显得很大。他走火溪路。“就是这，”他停下吉米车说。小径边有停车的地方，但没有车，只有雪和树，还有冰下的溪流。埃弗雷特没有回头看自己的生活。他扫视着空荡荡的出口，希望这不会是那种回头看时，会希望自己做点不同选择的时候，尽管当时做那件事似乎完全自然。
"Where's the car?" Bonnie asked. "This is where we parked," Clyde said. They were genuinely surprised and Everett almost laughed with relief. There was no con, no ambush. He untied the rope and the couple climbed out and walked to where their car had been. Bonnie's arm brushed against Everett's when she passed, but he didn't think she meant it. She was thinking about the missing car.
“车呢？”邦妮问。“我们停在这，”克莱德说。他们真的很惊讶，埃弗雷特几乎如释重负地笑了起来。没有诈骗，没有伏击。他解开绳子，这对夫妇下了车，走向他们车子本来的位置。邦妮路过时手臂擦过了埃弗雷特，但他觉得她不是故意的。她正在想那辆失踪的车。
He got in the Jimmy to let them discuss it. Pam reached into the way back to pull the saw and the axe from under the boughs Clyde and Bonnie had been sitting on, and she tucked the tools under her feet.
他回到吉米车上，让他们讨论。帕姆伸手进后舱，从克莱德和邦妮坐过的树枝下抽出锯子和斧头，把工具塞在脚下。
"What are we doing with these people in our car?" she asked. "Can't leave people in the snow," he said. "We have a child, Everett." "And," he said, with the confidence he had just now recovered, "we're showing her that you don't leave people in the snow. Right, Anne Marie?" "Right," Anne Marie said, but she watched them both. Pam gave Everett a dark, unforgiving stare.
“我们要带这些人在车里做什么？”她问。“不能把人丢在雪地里，”他说。“我们有孩子，埃弗雷特。”“而且，”他用刚恢复的自信说，“我们在教她，不能把人丢在雪地里。对吧，安妮·玛丽？”“对，”安妮·玛丽说，但她盯着他们俩。帕姆给了埃弗雷特一个阴沉、不可原谅的眼神。
Outside in the snow, Bonnie and Clyde's voices rose a notch. "You said we could leave the keys in it," Bonnie said. "You said this was Montana, and that's what people do." "That is what they do," Clyde said. "Then who stole our car?"
外面的雪地里，邦妮和克莱德的声音高了一个调。“你说我们可以把钥匙留在车里的，”邦妮说。“你说这是蒙大拿，人们都这么做。”“他们确实这么做，”克莱德说。“那谁偷了我们的车？”
Snow off the trees drifted around them, and the two stood staring at each other for a minute. Then Bonnie started to laugh. She had a throaty, movie star laugh that rose into a series of uncontrolled giggles. Her husband shook his head at her in exasperation. Everett felt the opposite. He liked her even more-- a woman who could laugh at her own stolen car and who looked like that when she did it.
树上的积雪在他们周围飘落，两人互相对视了一分钟。然后邦妮开始笑。她有一种喉音的、电影明星般的笑声，演变成一阵无法控制的咯咯笑。她丈夫懊恼地摇着头。埃弗雷特感觉恰恰相反。他更喜欢她了——一个能拿自己被偷的车开玩笑，而且笑起来还那么好看的女人。
She was still laughing when they started back to the car. "You ask for a ride," she told her husband, her voice not lowered enough. Ever looked to Pam in the backseat. Pam frowned, then nodded. He got out of the Jimmy, and this time Bonnie did brush his arm on purpose. He was sure of it.
当他们走回车边时，她还在笑。“你要求搭车，”她对丈夫说，声音压得不够低。埃弗雷特看向后座的帕姆。帕姆皱了皱眉，然后点点头。他下了吉米车，这一次邦妮确实故意擦过了他的手臂。他确定。
When she and Clyde were bundled in the way back again with the tree tied down, Everett called in the theft of the car on the CB. "Do you think we should wait for the cops," Clyde asked. "I'm not waiting in the cold anymore," Bonnie said. "Jesus, who steels a car at Christmas?" Clyde said, "People do all kinds of things at Christmas." No one had any response to that.
当她和克莱德再次蜷缩在后面，树也绑好后，埃弗雷特用CB报了车子被盗。“你觉得我们应该等警察吗，”克莱德问。“我不想再在寒冷中等了，”邦妮说。“天哪，谁会在圣诞节偷车？”克莱德说，“人们在圣诞节什么事都做得出来。”没人回应。
The road was empty and the sky was clear. Barbed-wire fences ran evenly beside the road. And the wooden posts ticked past as they drove. In the snowy fields beyond, yellow winter grass showed through in patches. Everett peered up at the tip of the tree, which seemed stable, roped to the roof.
路是空的，天空晴朗。带刺的铁丝网栅栏沿着路均匀分布。木桩在他们经过时咔哒咔哒响。在远处的雪地上，黄色的冬草露出点点斑块。埃弗雷特抬头看了一眼树尖，它似乎很稳定，用绳子绑在车顶。
After a while, Bonnie asked, "What do you do with the boughs?" "Make wreaths," Pam said. "I hope we're not crushing them." "No."
过了一会儿，邦妮问，“这些树枝打算怎么办？”“做花环，”帕姆说。“我希望我们没压坏它们。”“没有。”
The two women settled back into a silence just hostile enough that Everett could feel it. The white-capped mountains in the east beyond the low, yellow hills were lit up by the late sun through the clouds, and he was about to point them out to Anne Marie. "I broke the ski," Bonnie said out of the blue. "I was cold," she said, "so we tried to take a shortcut through some fallen trees with snow on them. Clyde took his skis off, but the snow was deep. And I tried to go over the logs. And the ski snapped right in half."
两个女人陷入了沉默，敌意恰好让埃弗雷特能感觉得到。低矮的黄色丘陵后，东方的白雪皑皑的山峰在云层中被夕阳照亮，他正要向安妮·玛丽指出。“我弄断了滑雪杖，”邦妮没来由地说，“我很冷，”她说，“所以我们试图抄近路穿过一些上面有积雪的倒木。克莱德脱了滑雪板，但雪太深了。我试图跨过圆木。滑雪杖就这么断成两截了。”
The sunlight had faded on the mountains, and Everett watched the road. "He came up here to find himself," Bonnie said, "from Arizona where we live. And he met this woman. She reminds me of you, actually." Pam glanced at Bonnie in surprise. "You're totally his type," Bonnie said. "Bonnie," Clyde said.
山上的阳光已经消退，埃弗雷特注视着路。“他来这里寻找自我，”邦妮说，“从我们居住的亚利桑那州。然后他遇到了这个女人。其实她挺像你的。”帕姆惊讶地看了邦妮一眼。“你完全是他的类型，”邦妮说。“邦妮，”克莱德说。
There's a long pause, and Everett wondered what his wife was thinking, if she was at all stirred by that. "Anyway," Bonnie went on, "this woman, she skis, and dives into glacial lakes, and canoes through rapids. And what doesn't she do? And he writes me and says that the air is so high and clear up here that he understands everything. And he has met his soulmate."
沉默了很久，埃弗雷特想知道妻子在想什么，她是否被这话触动。“总之，”邦妮继续说，“这个女人，她滑雪，潜入冰川湖，划独木舟穿过急流。有什么是她不做的？他给我写信说，这里的空气如此高爽清澈，他理解了一切。他遇到了灵魂伴侣。”
"Bonnie, shut up," Clyde said. "But we're married," Bonnie said. "And we have a child, so I have this crazy feeling that I'm supposed to be his soulmate. So I leave our son with my parents and come up here, too. And we go to a party, where people get naked in a hot tub and roll around in the snow. And I meet the woman, his perfect woman. And the first thing she does is proposition me."
“邦妮，闭嘴，”克莱德说。“但我们结婚了，”邦妮说。“而且我们有一个孩子，所以我有一种疯狂的感觉，我应该是他的灵魂伴侣。所以我把儿子留在我父母那，也来到这里。我们去参加了一个聚会，人们在热水浴缸里赤身裸体，在雪地里打滚。我见到了那个女人，他的完美女人。她做的第一件事就是向我求爱。”
Everett glanced at his daughter to see what she understood. He couldn't tell. She was looking straight out the windshield. He looked back at the road. "So I told Clyde about it," Bonnie said, "thinking he'd defend my honor. And he said it was a good idea. He thought we might just move into his soulmate's cabin and get along."
埃弗雷特瞥了一眼女儿，看她听懂了多少。他说不准。她正盯着挡风玻璃前方。他又看向路。“所以我告诉了克莱德，”邦妮说，“以为他会捍卫我的荣誉。他说这是个好主意。他以为我们可能会搬进他灵魂伴侣的小屋，和平相处。”
She seemed to think about this for a second, about the right way to sum it up. "So we tried to go for a mind-clearing ski," she said finally, "and the karma gods stole our car." She started to laugh again, the throaty start and then the giggle.
她似乎想了一秒钟，想总结得恰到好处。“所以我们试图去滑一场清心雪，”她最终说，“结果因果之神偷了我们的车。”她又开始笑，喉音的开头，接着是咯咯笑。
No one answered her. The only sound was her trying to stop laughing. Everett pulled quickly to the center of the road to miss a strip of black rubber truck tire.
没人回答她。唯一的声音是她试图止住笑。埃弗雷特迅速开向路中央，避开一条黑色的橡胶卡车轮胎。
The CB crackled on. "Continental Divide?" a voice asked. Everett answered that he was there. "You've been shot full of bullet holes?" the man asked. "Nope," Everett said. "That you reporting a stolen car?" "Have you seen it?" "Yeah," the voice said, "I just seen Baby Face Nelson driving it down the road. Ha. No, I ain't seen it. I'll keep an eye out." Everett thanked him and replaced the receiver.
CB无线电吱吱作响。“大陆分水岭？”一个声音问。埃弗雷特回答他在这里。“你被子弹打得满身窟窿了吗？”那个人问。“没，”埃弗雷特说。“是你报告车被偷了吗？”“你看到它了吗？”“是啊，”那个声音说，“我刚看到娃娃脸尼尔森开着它在路上。哈。不，我没看到。我会留意。”埃弗雷特道谢并放回了听筒。
"Why did he say Baby Face?" Anne Marie asked. "There was a Bonnie and Clyde," Everett told her, "not these ones, who were bank robbers. And Baby Face Nelson was a bank robber. But he didn't like to be called Baby Face."
“他为什么要说娃娃脸？”安妮·玛丽问。“有一个叫邦妮和克莱德的，”埃弗雷特告诉她，“不是这两个，是银行抢劫犯。娃娃脸尼尔森是个银行抢劫犯。但他不喜欢被叫娃娃脸。”
In the back, Bonnie said, "My first mistake was marrying someone named Clyde." "I don't recall you being real reluctant," Clyde said. "Do you have to talk about this here?" Pam burst out, and Everett was surprised. It wasn't like her to burst out, especially in front of strangers.
后面，邦妮说，“我犯的第一个错就是嫁给了一个叫克莱德的人。”“我不记得你当时很勉强，”克莱德说。“你非要在这里谈这个吗？”帕姆突然爆发，埃弗雷特很惊讶。她不是那种会爆发的人，尤其是在陌生人面前。
"We have to talk about it some time," Bonnie said. "We were supposed to be talking up here. Then we got lost, and I broke the ski. And Clyde goes crazy." "I did not go crazy." "You did," Bonnie said. Pam glared out the window with her arms crossed over her chest. Everett looked at the road.
“我们迟早得谈谈，”邦妮说。“我们本该在这里谈谈的。然后我们迷路了，我弄断了滑雪杖。克莱德就发疯了。”“我没发疯。”“你发了，”邦妮说。帕姆交叉双臂瞪着窗外。埃弗雷特看着路。
They were nearing the outskirts of town, the first houses. A few had decorations out-- Santas and snowmen. Windows were already lit with red and green outlines in the dim afternoon. "Should I take you to the police station?" Everett asked. "That would be great," Clyde said. "I'm sorry," Bonnie said. "This has been a hard time." There was a long silence.
他们快到镇郊了，第一批房屋出现。一些人摆出了装饰——圣诞老人和雪人。昏暗的午后，窗户已经亮起了红色和绿色的轮廓。“我该带你们去警察局吗？”埃弗雷特问。“那太好了，”克莱德说。“对不起，”邦妮说。“这真是一段艰难的时光。”沉默了很久。
"What's the little girl's name?" Bonnie asked. His daughter turned in her seat belt. "Anne Marie." "Do you have ornaments for the tree?" Bonnie asked her. "Yes," Anne Marie said. "What kind?" "Angels and two mice sleeping in a nutshell," she said, "and some fish." "Those sound nice," Bonnie said. "We've never had a tree. Clyde thinks you shouldn't cut down trees to put in your house."
“小女孩叫什么名字？”邦妮问。女儿在安全带里转过身。“安妮·玛丽。”“你们有圣诞树的装饰品吗？”邦妮问她。“有，”安妮·玛丽说。“什么样的？”“天使和两只睡在核桃壳里的老鼠，”她说，“还有一些鱼。”“听起来真不错，”邦妮说。“我们从没拥有过树。克莱德觉得你不该砍树放进屋里。”
"Bonnie," Clyde said. Anne Marie said, "Our tree was crowding up another tree, so we made the other tree have room." "Would that meet your standards, Clyde?" Bonnie asked. Clyde said nothing.
“邦妮，”克莱德说。安妮·玛丽说，“我们的树让另一棵树太挤了，所以我们让另一棵树有了空间。”“那符合你的标准吗，克莱德？”邦妮问。克莱德没说话。
Anne Marie looked out the windshield again, trained in the prevention of carsickness. "They could help decorate our tree," she said. "I think they want to find their car," Everett said. Anne Marie turned back in her seat. "Do you want to help with our tree?" "Honey, they're busy," Pam said.
安妮·玛丽又看向挡风玻璃，训练有素地预防晕车。“他们可以帮忙装饰我们的树，”她说。“我想他们想找到他们的车，”埃弗雷特说。安妮·玛丽在座位上转回来。“你们想帮忙装饰我们的树吗？”“宝贝，他们很忙，”帕姆说。
"I would love that more than anything in the world," Bonnie said. "No," her husband said. "Baby, please," Bonnie said. "We've never had a tree." "Leave these people alone," Clyde said.
“我愿意，比世界上任何事都愿意，”邦妮说。“不，”她丈夫说。“宝贝，求你了，”邦妮说。“我们从没拥有过树。”“别管这些人，”克莱德说。
Everett stopped at the police station. He untied the rope and opened the back of the Jimmy for his passengers. Clyde didn't get out right away. He said in a low voice to Pam, "Look, I'm really sorry about this. Thank you for the ride." Then he climbed out, past Everett, and walked with what seemed like dignity into the station.
埃弗雷特在警察局停下。他解开绳子，为乘客打开吉米车后舱。克莱德没有马上下来。他低声对帕姆说，“听着，这件事真的很抱歉。谢谢载我们。”然后他爬出来，越过埃弗雷特，带着似乎很有尊严的样子走进局里。
Bonnie sat on the boughs with her legs straight out and gave Everett a forlorn look. In her fur hat, she looked like a Russian doll. Pam had leaned forward and was talking quietly to Anne Marie in the front seat. "Why don't you go make your report," Everett told Bonnie. "See what they can do. I'll go home and unload and then come back and get you both."
邦妮坐在树枝上，腿伸直，给了埃弗雷特一个忧伤的眼神。戴着皮帽，她看起来像个俄罗斯套娃。帕姆俯身，在前座和安妮·玛丽小声说话。“你们去报案吧，”埃弗雷特告诉邦妮。“看看他们能做什么。我回家卸货，然后回来接你们俩。”
Two things happened at once, as in a movie-- one close up and one in deep focus. Bonnie broke into a brilliant tear-sparkled smile, and Pam's leaning form stiffened and she half turned her head. Then she looked away and occupied herself more fiercely with Anne Marie.
两件事同时发生，就像电影里一样——一个特写，一个深焦。邦妮露出了灿烂的、泪光闪烁的微笑，帕姆俯身的姿势僵住了，她半转过头。然后她移开视线，更专注地忙于照顾安妮·玛丽。
Bonnie clambered out of the back and kissed the side of Everett's mouth, her wool-bundled breasts pressing against him for a long second. "Thank you," she said.
邦妮爬出车后，亲了亲埃弗雷特嘴边，她那裹着羊毛的胸部紧压着他长达一秒。“谢谢，”她说。
Embarrassed, Everett stepped back and unlashed the skis and poles from the roof. He gave them to Bonnie, and she stood with the spiky bundle in her arms as Everett pulled away.
尴尬的埃弗雷特后退一步，解下车顶的滑雪板和滑雪杖。他把它们交给邦妮，埃弗雷特开车离开时，她站在那里，怀里抱着那捆尖锐的东西。
Pam said nothing as they drove. Their daughter must have felt the tension in the air. Everett whistled "chestnuts roasting on an open fire," for lack of anything more sensible to do.
帕姆开车时没说话。他们的女儿一定感觉到了空气中的紧张。埃弗雷特吹着《栗子在火上烤》，因为找不到更合适的举动。
At the house, he park the Jimmy and started untied the tree. Pam pulled the boughs out of the back, dumped them on the front deck, and took Anne Marie inside. Everett carried the tree around to the sliding glass door and tugged on the handle. The door didn't open. He thought it might be frozen. He tugged again. They never locked the doors.
到家后，他停下吉米车，开始解圣诞树。帕姆把树枝从后面拉出来，扔在前甲板上，带安妮·玛丽进了屋。埃弗雷特把树搬到推拉玻璃门前，拽了拽把手。门没开。他以为可能结冰了。他又拽了拽。他们从不锁门。
He went around the corner of the deck and pulled on the other sliding glass door, the one to the kitchen. It was locked too. He rapped on the glass, and Pam came to it. "The door's locked," he said, pointing to the handle. "Say you're not going back for them."
他走到甲板拐角处，拽另一扇推拉玻璃门，那是通往厨房的。也被锁上了。他敲了敲玻璃，帕姆走了过来。“门锁了，”他说，指向把手。“说你不会回去接他们。”
The tree was heavy on his shoulder, and he stood it up on the deck, holding the slender trunk through the branches. He studied it. It was a fine tree. He turned back to his wife. "It's Christmas," he said. "I don't want them here," she said through the glass. "Say you won't go." "Did you lock all the doors?" "Say it," she said.
树在他肩上很重，他把它立在甲板上，隔着树枝扶着细长的树干。他端详了一会儿。这是棵好树。他转向妻子。“现在是圣诞节，”他说。“我不想他们来这，”她透过玻璃说。“说你不会去。”“你把所有门都锁了吗？”“说出来，”她说。
He sighed. The temperature dropped, and it was cold. "I won't go back for them," he said. "I'll leave them stranded and unhappy without a tree at Christmas time. Are you happy?" "They're crazy," she said. "Of course they are. Now let me in."
他叹了口气。气温骤降，很冷。“我不会回去接他们，”他说。“我会让他们孤零零、不开心地过一个没有圣诞树的圣诞节。你满意了吗？”“他们是疯子，”她说。“当然是。现在让我进去。”
She unlocked the door. He carried the tree through the kitchen, set it up in the corner of the living room, and turned it until the bare side faced the wall. Pam was right. It looked like a lopsided bush. Anne Marie clapped her hands in approval. He showed her how to fill the reservoir in the stand with water. Then he crumpled the newspaper in the fireplace, built the hut of kindling, and set it alight.
她开了锁。他把树搬进厨房，立在客厅角落，转动它直到光秃秃的一面贴墙。帕姆说得对。它看起来像个长歪的灌木丛。安妮·玛丽鼓掌表示赞许。他教她如何给架子底座加水。然后他在壁炉里弄皱报纸，搭起火绒小屋，点火。
Pam called the police station to renege on the hospitality, asking them to deliver the message to the people whose car was stolen. Everett strung lights on the tree and lifted Anne Marie to put the angel on top. There wasn't really a single top to the tree, but he helped her pick one.
帕姆给警察局打了电话拒绝好客，要求他们给那对车子被盗的人传话。埃弗雷特给树挂上灯，抱起安妮·玛丽把天使放在顶端。树其实没有真正的顶端，但他帮她选了一个。
Pam moved around the kitchen, making dinner. Anne Marie gamely kept up an almost professional patter, like a hostess who knows her party has gone wrong and her guests are miserable. Everett sat in a big chair between the fireplace and the kitchen, feeling the soreness from chopping and hauling set in. He wasn't 25 anymore.
帕姆在厨房里忙碌，准备晚餐。安妮·玛丽乖巧地保持着一种近乎专业的闲聊，就像一个知道聚会搞砸了、客人很悲惨的主人。埃弗雷特坐在壁炉和厨房之间的一张大椅子里，感受着砍树和搬运带来的酸痛。他不再是25岁了。
Leaving a pot of soup on the stove, Pam made a juniper swag for the mantelpiece, her slimness in jeans set off by the firelight. She nestled three white candles among the branches, evenly spaced, and lit them. Everett watch her, thinking about the fact that she was Clyde's type and wondering why he still wanted to go get the outlaws and put himself in the way of temptation.
把一锅汤留在炉子上，帕姆为壁炉架做了一个杜松花环，壁炉火光衬托出她牛仔裤下的苗条身材。她在树枝间均匀地插上三支白蜡烛，点燃。埃弗雷特看着她，想着她是克莱德那一款的，并想知道为什么他仍然想去接那些亡命徒，把自己置身于诱惑中。
Pam turned from the mantel. There was sometimes a funny, ironic smile that came over her face when she caught him looking at her, a grownup smile, at once confident and self-deprecating. But now she looked defiant and young. Pam put a hand on her hip.
帕姆从壁炉架转过身。当她发现他在注视自己时，脸上有时会浮现出一种有趣、讽刺的微笑，一种成熟的微笑，既自信又自嘲。但现在她看起来挑衅而年轻。帕姆双手叉腰。
"Look, if you want to go get them, just go." "They'll have gone by now," he said, with a catch in his voice. Pam threw the burnt matches into the fire. In the kitchen, she put the matchbook in the kitchen drawer, then she dialed the phone, watching Everett as if waiting for him to stop her. "I called earlier about the couple with the stolen car," she said in her business-like phone voice. "Are they still there?"
“听着，如果你想去接他们，就去吧。”“他们现在肯定已经走了，”他声音哽咽地说。帕姆把烧焦的火柴扔进火里。在厨房，她把火柴盒放进抽屉，然后拨了电话，注视着埃弗雷特，仿佛在等他阻止自己。“我之前打过电话，关于那对车子被偷的夫妇，”她用那种公事公办的语气说。“他们还在吗？”
She waited, looking out the dark, glass door she had locked against him. "Hi, Bonnie," she said into the phone. "It's Pam from the car. We picked you up. Hi." Her laugh sounded social, but Everett could hear the nervousness in it. "No, I don't think I introduced myself. Do you still want to help with the tree? Everett could run down and get you."
她等着，望着她曾为他锁上的黑暗玻璃门。“嗨，邦妮，”她对着电话说。“我是车上的帕姆。我们接你们的。嗨。”她的笑声听起来很社交，但埃弗雷特能听出其中的紧张。“不，我想我还没自我介绍。你们还想帮忙装饰圣诞树吗？埃弗雷特可以跑一趟去接你们。”
She paused, listening. "Put Clyde on," she said, and she turned away from Everett. He watched the curve of his wife's ass as she leaned on the kitchen counter, lifting her right foot and nervously tapping the toe on the floor. "Clyde," she said, "please come up for dinner. Anne Marie would love to show off the tree. Really, we'd love it. Good, he'll be right down." She hung up the phone and turned to Everett. "Merry Christmas," she said.
她停下来听。“让克莱德接电话，”她说，然后背对着埃弗雷特。他看着妻子靠在厨台上时臀部的曲线，抬起右脚紧张地用脚尖敲击地面。“克莱德，”她说，“请过来吃晚餐吧。安妮·玛丽会很高兴展示圣诞树的。真的，我们很期待。好的，他马上就来。”她挂断电话转向埃弗雷特。“圣诞快乐，”她说。
He was not sure how to behave. Anne Marie was still decorating the lower branches of the tree. "So," Pam said. She stirred the pot on the stove with a wooden spoon, "Do you want to go get them?" Everett pushed himself out of the chair. "Want to come along, Anne Marie?" he asked. His daughter looked up at him. "Are you going to get those people?" "Yes," he said, "to help with the tree."
他不知道该怎么表现。安妮·玛丽还在装饰圣诞树的下层树枝。“那么，”帕姆说。她用木勺搅拌炉子上的锅，“你想去接他们吗？”埃弗雷特推开椅子起身。“想一起去吗，安妮·玛丽？”他问。女儿抬头看着他。“你要去接那些人吗？”“是的，”他说，“来帮忙装饰圣诞树。”
Anne Marie nodded, untangling the loop of string on a tiny ukulele. "I'll stay here," she said. He kissed his wife goodbye on the top of her head. Was she attracted to Clyde? He wanted to take off her clothes right now and see. He was conscious of his own breathing, and he could tell she was unsteady. "It's Christmastime," he said. "I'll be right back."
安妮·玛丽点点头，解开一个小尤克里里上的弦。“我留在这里，”她说。他亲吻了妻子的头顶告别。她真的被克莱德吸引了吗？他现在就想脱掉她的衣服看看。他能感觉到自己的呼吸，也能看出她很不稳定。“现在是圣诞节，”他说。“我马上回来。”
He went out into the cold air. The Jimmy started up easily, and he had it in low gear down the hill toward town. He wanted to decide as he drove what they were doing. He wanted to separate his impulse to be a good Samaritan from the kiss on the corner of his mouth.
他走进寒冷的空气中。吉米车很容易就发动了，他挂低档向山下的镇子开去。他想在开车时决定他们在做什么。他想把善良救助的冲动与嘴角的那个吻分开。
Bonnie did not, he was fairly sure, just want to hang angels on a tree. Clyde's asking her to move in with his mistress had put her in a giddy, reckless mood, and Everett was the beneficiary. He wasn't going to think about Clyde's low, sincere apology to Pam or about Pam turning away on the phone to ask Clyde to come to the house. Although he found he wanted very much to think about that.
他相当肯定，邦妮不仅仅是想在圣诞树上挂天使。克莱德要求她搬进他情妇的小屋，这让她处于一种轻浮、鲁莽的情绪中，而埃弗雷特是受益者。他不想去想克莱德对帕姆的那些低沉、真诚的道歉，或者帕姆在电话里转身请克莱德到家里来。尽管他发现自己非常想去想那些。
He thought instead about Anne Marie and how the evening might work out for her. The lesson about not abandoning people was a good one. The silent, submerged unhappiness of the evening couldn't be good for a kid. And now it was gone, dissolved by Pam's call into the buzz of unsettled excitement.
他转而想到安妮·玛丽，想到这个夜晚可能会对她产生什么影响。关于不遗弃人的教训是很好的。沉默、压抑的夜晚对孩子不好。现在，一切都消失了，被帕姆的电话溶解进不安的兴奋中。
The streets were dark and empty, the houses warm with light. He wanted to keep thinking, but he was at the station before he'd sorted things out. And Bonnie was waiting on the curb. She climbed into the front seat and kicked the snow off her boots. "Hi," she said, and she clutched her hands in her lap. She shuddered once from nervousness or cold. "Clyde'll be here in a second," she said, "he's signing something about the car." "OK," he said.
街道黑暗而空旷，房屋在灯光中温暖。他想继续思考，但在梳理清楚之前就到了警局。邦妮在路边等候。她爬上副驾驶座，踢掉靴子上的雪。“嗨，”她说，把手绞在一起放在膝盖上。因为紧张或寒冷，她颤抖了一下。“克莱德马上就来，”她说，“他在签关于车子的东西。”“好的，”他说。
She looked at Everett and seemed about to say something, and then she was in his arms. He gathered her up as well as he could given her thick coat and the awkward position and kissed her sweet face. Her cheeks were cold, but her lips were warm, and she was trembling. The peacoat was unbuttoned and he reached inside to feel the curve of her breast through her sweater. A second later, they pulled apart and Bonnie smoothed her hair.
她看着埃弗雷特，似乎想说什么，然后投入了他的怀抱。考虑到厚重的外套和尴尬的位置，他尽可能地拥抱她，亲吻她甜美的脸庞。她的脸颊冰冷，但嘴唇温暖，她正在颤抖。短大衣没扣扣子，他伸手进去，透过毛衣感受她乳房的曲线。一秒钟后，他们分开，邦妮梳理头发。
The lighted glass door of the police station opened, and Clyde walked with his long stride toward them and got in the backseat. Everett thought there must be a smell in the car from the kiss, an electricity. But the husband said nothing, and Everett drove the outlaws back to his house. They talked about the stolen car, and the cold, and the tree. All the while, Everett felt both the threat of disorder and the steady, thrumming promise of having everything he wanted all at once.
警察局亮灯的玻璃门开了，克莱德迈着大步向他们走来，钻进后座。埃弗雷特以为车里一定会有那种亲吻留下的气味，那种电流感。但丈夫什么也没说，埃弗雷特载着这些亡命徒回到家。他们谈论失窃的车、寒冷和树。一路上，埃弗雷特既感受到了混乱的威胁，也感受到了同时拥有想要的一切的那种稳定、悸动的希望。
Maile Meloy. This story appears in her book, Both Ways is the Only Way I Want It.
梅莉·梅洛伊。这个故事出现在她的书《两种方式是我想要的唯一方式》中。
[MUSIC - "MAKE YOU BETTER" BY THE DECEMBERISTS"]
[音乐 - 乐队The Decemberists的《让你要更好》]
Coming up, why some Republican leaders in North Carolina are feeling weird about Santa Claus this year. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，为什么北卡罗来纳州的一些共和党领袖今年对圣诞老人感到怪怪的。稍后从芝加哥公共广播电台继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today, Just What I Wanted. We've arrived at Act Two of our program, Act Two. He's making a list, checking it nice. Gonna find out who voted twice. So this fall, what certain Republicans thought they would discover under the tree was proof of voter fraud. This, of course, is one of the big divisive issues that separate the Right and the Left in our country. Democrats in the mainstream media point out that there is no evidence of significant voter fraud happening in our elections. Republicans say that it easily could be happening, given the way our elections are run, and we do not have the tools to track it.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目，《恰如我愿》。我们已经来到节目的第二幕，第二幕。他列了个清单，核对得很仔细。要找出谁投了两次票。所以今年秋天，某些共和党人以为在圣诞树下会发现的是选民欺诈的证据。当然，这是分裂我们国家右派和左派的重大问题之一。民主党人和主流媒体指出，没有证据表明在我们的选举中存在重大的选民欺诈。共和党人说，考虑到我们选举的运作方式，这种情况很容易发生，而且我们没有跟踪它的工具。
And this year, the place where the search has been the most intense for voter fraud was North Carolina. And this time, Zoe Chace reports, Republicans really had moments when they thought they had found proof of organized fraud.
而今年，北卡罗来纳州是选民欺诈搜查最激烈的地方。而这一次，据佐伊·蔡斯报道，共和党人确实有那么一刻以为他们发现了组织欺诈的证据。
The man leading the hunt for voter fraud in North Carolina is Dallas Woodhouse, executive director of the North Carolina Republican Party. Picture a Southern party boss. It's probably Dallas-- white guy in an Oxford shirt, bottom buttons undone, loafers, no socks--
北卡罗来纳州选民欺诈调查的负责人是达拉斯·伍德豪斯，北卡罗来纳州共和党执行董事。想象一个南方政党老板。很可能是达拉斯——穿着牛津衬衫，下面没扣扣子，没穿袜子的乐福鞋——
Are you really smoking a cigar right now?
你现在真的在抽雪茄吗？
I am.
我是。
--a cigar in the corner of his mouth. Younger and handsomer than you're imagining, I think. He used to be a TV anchor. He's trying to cut back on cigars since the election ended. I point out there have been a lot of studies looking into voter fraud that conclude voter fraud is minuscule, almost nonexistent.
——嘴边叼着雪茄。比你们想象的更年轻、更帅气。他曾是电视主播。选举结束后他正试图少抽雪茄。我指出，已经有很多研究调查选民欺诈，结论是选民欺诈微乎其微，几乎不存在。
I think that if you see any study, there is no study that ever points to--
我想如果你看任何研究，没有研究会指出——
You know, look, look.
你知道，看，看。
Look, I've got to say this.
看，我得说这个。
Don't show me studies. Academics, I mean, a bunch of knuckleheads, pointy-headed professors. We deal in the real world.
别给我看研究。那些学者，我是说，一群蠢蛋，尖头教授。我们处理的是现实世界。
In the real world, Dallas looks for voter fraud, he will tell you, as a matter of principle. There was also a numbers game going on this November. The Republican governor of North Carolina refused to concede the election for weeks because it was such a close race. At the moment I met Dallas, the governor was down just 8,500 votes out of 4.7 million. There were other close races also.
在现实世界中，达拉斯会告诉你，他寻找选民欺诈是基于原则。今年11月还有一个数字游戏。北卡罗来纳州的共和党州长几周来拒绝承认选举结果，因为竞争太激烈。我和达拉斯见面时，州长在470万张选票中落后仅8500票。还有其他激烈的竞争。
Dallas was out running down every claim of voter fraud around the state. His team accused people of voting twice. That was dismissed. People who voted when they were dead, that was dismissed. Felons who voted.
达拉斯一直在追查全州所有选民欺诈的指控。他的团队指控有人投了两次票。被驳回了。死人投票，被驳回了。重罪犯投票。
Yeah, but we made a challenge. It ended up not being correct, of a person who showed up on the felon list. And we found somebody that voted, had the same first name, same last name, same birth date. It turns out it wasn't the same person. It seems like to me you have to make an attempt to address that.
是啊，但我们提出了质疑。最终证明是不正确的，有人出现在重罪犯名单上。我们发现有人投票，名字相同，姓氏相同，出生日期相同。结果发现不是同一个人。在我看来，你必须尝试去解决这个问题。
Dallas found 24 ineligible felons out of 43 they accused. He's not perfect.
达拉斯在他们指控的43人中发现了24名不合格的重罪犯。他不完美。
Look, I'm not-- the only perfect person I know walked on water, and he's my Savior, Jesus Christ. We are not perfect.
看，我不是——我知道唯一完美的人是曾经在水上行走的那位，他是我的救主耶稣基督。我们不完美。
The day we talk, Dallas has a smoking gun, a few hundred ballots in the southeast of the state, lots with the same handwriting on them. Jackpot. He takes a breath.
我们谈话的那天，达拉斯有了确凿证据，该州东南部有几百张选票，很多笔迹相同。大奖。他深吸了一口气。
They do realize that 300 or 400 write-in votes can't be done by one person. They do realize that's illegal.
他们确实意识到300或400张填写票不可能由一个人完成。他们确实意识到那是违法的。
Here's what happened. Down in Bladen County, North Carolina, this guy Brian was going through absentee balance at the Board of Elections. He's a board member, a Republican. His job was to scrutinize each ballot as it came out of the machine. He's heard a lot about voter fraud, never seen it before, but he believes it's widespread. He's heard a lot about it on the news. His eyes are peeled.
发生的事情是这样的。在北卡罗来纳州的布雷登县，这个叫布莱恩的家伙正在选举委员会审查缺席选票。他是一名董事会成员，共和党人。他的工作是审查从机器里出来的每一张选票。他听说过很多关于选民欺诈的事，以前从没见过，但他相信它很普遍。他在新闻里听说过很多。他瞪大了眼睛。
And then he notices something. Way down at the bottom of the ballot, there was room for a write-in candidate, the county soil and water district supervisor. And he kept seeing the name Franklin Graham.
然后他注意到了一些东西。在选票的最下方，有一个填写候选人的空格，是县土壤和水资源区主管的。他一直看到“富兰克林·格雷厄姆”这个名字。
And it looked like the same handwriting a lot of times.
而且看起来很多时候笔迹都一样。
He demonstrates by writing the name in my notebook.
他通过在我的笔记本上写下这个名字来演示。
Every time I write this, my R's are going to be the same. My A's are pretty much going to be the same. My K's are going to be the same. So if I write it again as you watch.
每次我写这个时，我的R都会一样。我的A基本上都会一样。我的K基本上都会一样。所以如果我再写一次，看着。
Franklin Graham.
富兰克林·格雷厄姆。
You see similarities between certain letters every time.
你每次都能看到某些字母之间的相似之处。
Like how many times?
有多少次？
Considerable, I would say, I don't, 50 to 100.
相当多，我会说，我不知道，50到100次。
Of one person putting in 100 votes.
一个人投了100票。
You could infer that.
你可以推断出这一点。
In all, maybe 300 ballots. Brian is a paramedic. He's used to looking at EKG waveforms. He says he has an eye for patterns like the way someone writes their name. Brian is also pretty careful. He wasn't sure it was fraud. But it looked suspicious.
总共可能有300张选票。布莱恩是一名护理人员。他习惯看心电图波形。他说他对模式有眼光，比如别人写名字的方式。布莱恩也很谨慎。他不确定那是否是欺诈。但看起来很可疑。
I wouldn't infer that, because obviously I'm not an expert. But you could infer that.
我不会那样推断，因为显然我不是专家。但你可以推断出这一点。
Dallas Woodhouse does more than infer.
达拉斯·伍德豪斯做的不仅仅是推断。
Come on. You cannot look at me in a straight face and think the same handwriting puts in several hundred votes for one person and not call that fraud. That is the definition of fraud.
得了吧。你不可能看着我的脸，认为同一个人为某人投了几百票，而不称之为欺诈。这正是欺诈的定义。
It wasn't just one person's handwriting. It was around a dozen people. Dallas has a term for what he thinks this is. He calls it an absentee ballot mill. This is what he pictures when he hears about all these ballots with the same handwriting on them. Key Democratic operatives, running around searching for old people who barely know their own names and then filling out ballots for them. A blatant scheme, Dallas thinks, that gins up votes for the Democrats. And the Democratic governor, remember, is only up by a couple thousand votes.
那不仅仅是一个人的笔迹。大约有十几个人。达拉斯对这件事有一个称呼。他称之为“缺席选票工厂”。当他听到所有这些笔迹相同的选票时，他想象的就是这个画面。民主党的关键操盘手四处寻找那些几乎连自己名字都不知道的老人，然后为他们填写选票。达拉斯认为这是一个明目张胆的计划，为民主党赚取选票。记住，那位民主党州长只领先了几千票。
Should the election board find that these are absentee ballot mills, with the purpose of fraudulent voting, those people should go to jail. They should go to jail. They should spend the first term of the Trump administration behind bars.
如果选举委员会发现这些是缺席选票工厂，目的是进行欺诈性投票，这些人就应该坐牢。他们应该坐牢。他们应该在特朗普政府的第一个任期里待在监狱里。
I go down south to meet the victims of the alleged scheme, the democratic voters of Bladen County. It is an unusual interviewing situation.
我去了南方，去见据称是该计划的受害者，布雷登县的民主党选民。这是一种不寻常的采访情况。
This is Zoe.
这是佐伊。
Hi.
嗨。
She's out of New York. She has a talk radio show.
她是纽约来的。她有一个谈话广播节目。
I'm at a senior center in this classroom. I'm standing up at the front with a microphone like a teacher. There are rows of older people sitting quietly, staring back at me. Their dominoes game is sealed up in a Tupperware. I go from person to person and ask each one about their vote while everyone else silently watches. It's awkward.
我站在老人中心的一间教室里。我像老师一样站在前面拿着麦克风。一排排的老年人安静地坐着，盯着我看。他们的多米诺骨牌游戏被封在特百惠盒子里。我从一个人走到另一个人，每个人都在沉默地看着的情况下问每个人的投票情况。很尴尬。
May I ask you about your vote? OK.
我可以问问你的投票吗？好的。
Her name is Lula Pearl Graham. She did vote absentee this year. She says someone helped her get an absentee ballot in. This person worked with a political PAC, the Bladen County Improvement Association PAC. And she followed their advice on how to vote. They gave her a sample ballot with a slate of endorsed candidates.
她叫卢拉·珀尔·格雷厄姆。她今年确实投了缺席选票。她说有人帮她拿到了一张缺席选票。这个人与一个政治行动委员会（PAC）合作，即布雷登县改进协会PAC。她听从了他们关于如何投票的建议。他们给了她一张样本选票，上面列有支持的候选人名单。
Did you know everybody who you were voting for on the ballot this year?
你今年知道选票上你要投给谁吗？
No, I didn't.
不，不知道。
But did you know who you were voting for for governor?
但你知道你要投给州长吗？
Yeah.
是的。
OK. What about for soil and water? Can I ask you who you voted for there? Do you know?
好的。那么土壤和水资源呢？我可以问问你投给了谁吗？你知道吗？
I don't remember.
我不记得了。
But do you trust their recommendations? The PAC with the sample ballot and everything?
但你信任他们的推荐吗？那个带有样本选票的PAC等等？
Oh, yes, they're good. They're good.
哦，是的，他们很好。他们很好。
Why?
为什么？
Because when you don't know the people, they'll tell you-- they explain them to you. So you say, well, I would like to vote here, but I don't know who this is. They tell you.
因为当你不知道这些人时，他们会告诉你——他们为你解释。所以你会说，嗯，我想投这里，但我不知道这是谁。他们会告诉你。
What she's describing doesn't sound illegal. If the PAC bought her vote, it would be illegal. If the PAC threatened her, it would be illegal. Giving someone a slate of candidates to vote for is not illegal. Having someone assist you in filling out your ballot is not illegal. Though if you do assist someone, you're supposed to give them some space while they actually vote and then sign the envelope saying you assisted them. But I do think if Dallas, the Republican guy, chewed his cigar into this room and heard Lula Pearl talk, he would be horrified, based on how he thinks about this stuff.
她所描述的听起来并不违法。如果PAC买了她的选票，那是违法的。如果PAC威胁她，那是违法的。给某人一张候选人名单投票不是违法的。让某人协助你填写选票不是违法的。虽然如果你确实协助某人，你应该在他们实际投票时给他们一些空间，然后签署信封声明你协助了他们。但我确实认为，如果达拉斯，那个共和党人，咀嚼着雪茄走进这个房间，听到卢拉·珀尔这么说，基于他对此事的看法，他会感到震惊。
Under a select few circumstances, you can get assistance from a relative or somebody who declares your help. Now, that is intended to be a neighbor helping a neighbor, a friend helping a friend. If somebody is going out there and helping hundreds of people, they are harvesting ballots.
在极少数情况下，你可以从亲戚或某人那里获得协助，声明你是需要帮助的。现在，那本来应该是邻里互助、朋友互助。如果有人出去帮助成百上千的人，他们就是在“收割选票”。
For Dallas, Lula Pearl saying she doesn't know anything about the candidates she's voting for but votes for them anyway, at the suggestion of volunteers who get $35 a day reimbursement for gas and food, that's shady to Dallas on its face. If it's not technically illegal, it should be. It's supposed to be one person, one vote. As soon as you have one person helping lots and lots of people vote, it feels like a scheme to him. Lula Pearl sees it differently. Having a volunteer come to the house makes it easier for her to vote. She wants it.
对于达拉斯来说，卢拉·珀尔说她对投票的候选人一无所知，但仍然投票，是在那些每天获得35美元汽油和食物补贴的志愿者的建议下完成的，这在达拉斯看来显然是可疑的。如果从技术上讲不违法，也应该违法。应该是“一人一票”。一旦你有一个人帮助很多人投票，对他来说就像是一个阴谋。卢拉·珀尔的看法不同。有一个志愿者来家里让她投票更容易。她想要这样。
I don't drive, and I have two knee implants. Sometimes it's difficult to get around. So somebody would come and pick me up. But sometimes I don't feel like going that way. So I just let someone come and vote for me and let-- come and let me fill out the application. And then it goes, and it comes back.
我不开车，而且我做了两次膝盖植入手术。有时候走动很困难。所以有人会来接我。但有时候我不想那样去。所以我就让人来帮我投，让人——来让我填写申请表。然后它寄出，再回来。
Voting is very important to her. She feels like, why shouldn't it be easy?
投票对她来说非常重要。她觉得，为什么不简单点呢？
My mother and my father, they marched all the way from Selma, Alabama to Birmingham, Alabama for the right for me to vote. And I'm going to vote.
我的母亲和父亲，他们为了我投票的权利，从阿拉巴马州的塞尔玛一直游行到阿拉巴马州的伯明翰。我会去投票的。
This is, in fact, why this organization that helped her with the ballot exists, the Bladen County Improvement Association PAC. It exists to protect the vote for black people in the community.
事实上，这就是那个帮她投票的组织——布雷登县改进协会PAC存在的原因。它的存在是为了保护社区中黑人的投票权。
The head of the PAC is Horace Munn. Horace Munn-- for a man allegedly at the center of a blatant scheme to rig an election-- Horace is pretty easy to find. Like, I couldn't get any service on my phone driving down to Bladen County, so I went into this convenience store at the side of the road. Tammy let me use her phone. She goes, oh, you're talking to Horace? That's my godfather. Let me have the phone. Horace, where do you want me to send her?
PAC的负责人是霍勒斯·曼恩。霍勒斯·曼恩——对于一个据称处于操纵选举阴谋中心的家伙——霍勒斯其实很容易找到。就像，我开车去布雷登县时手机没信号，所以我就进了路边这家便利店。塔米让我用了她的电话。她说，哦，你要和霍勒斯说话？那是我教父。把电话给我。霍勒斯，你想让我把她送到哪？
He was at the town hall in East Arcadia. He's on the town council. He's the fire chief. Horace is a former soldier, a paratrooper, got the Bronze Star in the First Gulf War. He uses that old civil rights era language like, I fought for freedom abroad, but we're not free at home.
他在东阿卡迪亚的市政厅。他是市议员。他是消防队长。霍勒斯是一名退伍军人、伞兵，在第一次海湾战争中获得铜星勋章。他使用那些民权时代的语言，比如，“我在国外为自由而战，但在家却没有自由。”
I served to make sure that we all get freedom in America. And I come home, and I find out that they say that we're free but in actuality, we're not. They say things are equal, but in actuality, they're not.
我服役是为了确保我们在美国都能享有自由。我回家后，发现他们说我们是自由的，但实际上我们不是。他们说万物平等，但实际上并非如此。
Meaning black voters in this area have been subject to extra scrutiny, to harassment, extra rules, all things that keep them from voting. This is how Horace sees it. The PAC exists to get people to the polls and also bring black people together as a voting bloc. And he says, yes, his group was behind the campaign to get people to write in Franklin Graham for soil and water supervisor. And he explains it. Basically, there was an incumbent running unopposed. They did not like him. So Horace decided, let's get my buddy Franklin Graham on the ballot.
意思是这个地区的黑人选民一直受到额外审查、骚扰、额外规定，所有这些都阻碍他们投票。霍勒斯就是这么看的。PAC的存在是为了把人们带到投票站，并让黑人作为一个投票集团聚集在一起。他说，是的，他的组织确实支持让人们填写“富兰克林·格雷厄姆”为土壤和水资源主管候选人的运动。他解释了原因。基本上，有一位在职候选人无人竞争。他们不喜欢他。所以霍勒斯决定，让我的伙伴富兰克林·格雷厄姆出现在选票上。
Well, I missed the window. I missed the window to get his name placed on the ballot.
嗯，我错过了窗口期。我错过了让他的名字出现在选票上的窗口期。
Does Franklin Graham actually know anything about what it takes to take care of soil and water as a district supervisor?
富兰克林·格雷厄姆真的知道担任地区主管需要照顾土壤和水资源吗？
No.
不知道。
The soil and water supervisor, as far as I can figure, keeps the water from being contaminated by the soil and the soil from being eroded by the water. In any way, the incumbent didn't have any special expertise either when he got the job. That's what Horace thinks. I asked Horace about why so many of the ballots seem to have Franklin Graham's name written out in the same handwriting. But he can't discuss the Franklin Graham thing. It's under investigation. And while Lula Pearl's vote seems legit, there are about 300 others that might not be.
据我所知，土壤和水资源主管负责防止水被土壤污染，并防止土壤被水侵蚀。无论如何，那个在职者在得到这份工作时也没有任何特别的专业知识。霍勒斯就是这么想的。我问霍勒斯为什么这么多选票似乎都是用同样的笔迹写着富兰克林·格雷厄姆的名字。但他无法讨论富兰克林·格雷厄姆的事。它正在调查中。虽然卢拉·珀尔的票看起来合法，但大约有300张可能不是。
There is an official body that decides whether it's voter fraud or not, the State Board of Elections. And on a Saturday afternoon, they have a special hearing to decide who's right in this case.
有一个官方机构来决定那是不是选民欺诈，即州选举委员会。在一个周六下午，他们举行了一次特别听证会来决定谁在这个案子里是对的。
We are here to conduct two hearings. We assume jurisdiction that--
我们在这里举行两场听证会。我们假设管辖权——
The board is rushing to rule on all these election protests coming in so the state can actually have a governor. The Republican governor still hasn't conceded the race. The election is up in the air. It's not made for TV. It's not even a courtroom. It's a badly lit press conference-style space. Rows of chairs are just dragged in. There are five board members who will decide things. Three Republicans, two Democrats, a big audience, a slew of lawyers at the table.
委员会正忙着裁决所有这些涌进来的抗议选举的案件，以便该州能真正拥有一位州长。共和党州长仍然没有承认选举结果。选举悬而未决。这不是为了电视节目准备的。这甚至不是法庭。这是一个照明很差的新闻发布会风格的空间。椅子是临时拖进来的。有五位委员将做出决定。三名共和党人，两名民主党人，一大群观众，桌子旁坐着一大批律师。
Did you say the vote should be discounted or the ballots should be discounted?
你是说选票应该折算，还是应该废弃？
The entire ballot should be discounted.
整张选票都应该废弃。
The governor's lawyers come off a little sloppy. Because a few hours in, the complaint starts to fall apart in this kind of mortifying way. It happens when the person who actually filed the complaint against the Bladen County Improvement Association PAC takes the stand.
州长的律师们看起来有点草率。因为几个小时后，投诉开始以这种令人羞辱的方式分崩离析。这是当真正提出针对布雷登县改进协会PAC投诉的人站在证人席上时发生的。
How you doing, sir?
你好吗，先生？
Doing fine, Mr. Michael.
很好，迈克尔先生。
McCrae Dowless. He's actually the guy who won the soil and water supervisor race in Bladen County. And he takes the stand looking like he's not quite ready for this. He doesn't have a suit. He's got a big beard, skinny guy, windbreaker. And once he's up there being questioned by one of the Democrats on the Board of Elections, he seems amazingly unfamiliar with his own case.
麦克雷·道利斯。他实际上就是布雷登县土壤和水资源主管选举的获胜者。他站在证人席上，看起来还没准备好。他没穿西装。他留着大胡子，瘦瘦的家伙，穿着防风夹克。当他被选举委员会的一名民主党人审问时，他对自己的案子似乎显得非常陌生。
You allege that there was a scheme that was taking place in Bladen County, correct? That's the words that you used-- "blatant scheme"? What did you mean by that?
你指控布雷登县发生了一个阴谋，对吗？这就是你用的词——“明目张胆的阴谋”？你是什么意思？
Scheme?
阴谋？
You used the words, "resulting from a blatant scheme."
你用了“源于一个明目张胆的阴谋”这些词。
Are you saying I used the words or the attorney that wrote that up used the words?
你是说我用了这些词，还是写下这些词的律师用了这些词？
Well, it's got your signature at the end.
嗯，最后有你的签名。
It's got my signature here on it. But as far as writing that personal-- writing that up, I didn't do that. The attorney did. The attorney was the one that drew the protest up.
这上面确实有我的签名。但就写那个人而言——写下来，我没做。是律师做的。是律师起草了抗议书。
He tries to remember who that attorney is, like what his name is.
他试图回忆那个律师是谁，叫什么名字。
I can't think of the gentlemen's name. Steve? I can't remember his last name.
我想不起那位先生的名字了。史蒂夫？我不记得他的姓了。
His attorneys seem embarrassed. It is embarrassing when a client who's supposedly lodging a complaint is not familiar with the complaint. They try to object. It doesn't work. McCrae just ignores his lawyers and keeps talking over them. I look over at Horace Munn from the PAC, and he is all giddy. He's tapping his lawyer, spinning around in his seat. He pulls his glasses down his nose and makes eyes at me.
他的律师看起来很尴尬。当一个假定提出投诉的客户不熟悉投诉内容时，这是令人尴尬的。他们试图反对。没用。麦克雷只是无视他的律师，继续说话压过他们。我看向PAC的霍勒斯·曼恩，他兴奋极了。他在拍他的律师，在座位上转来转去。他把眼镜拉下鼻梁，向我抛媚眼。
The hearing goes on for five hours. Some people who wrote in the name Franklin Graham on 300-odd ballots broke the rules by not signing the envelope, saying they assisted the voters in filling out the ballots. But over those hours, no one disputes that real voters cast those votes. Finally, one of the Republicans on the election's board says he's not buying this as a massive ballot scheme that's thwarting the Republican governor.
听证会进行了五个小时。一些人在300多张选票上填写富兰克林·格雷厄姆名字的人打破了规则，没有在信封上签名，说明他们协助选民填写选票。但在这几个小时里，没有人质疑是真实的选民投了这些票。最终，选举委员会的一名共和党人说，他不相信这是一个阻挠共和党州长的巨大选票阴谋。
There does not appear to be any dispute that the signatures of the voters on all the ballots are proper. And I think that's something that I would have to hear before all of you wanting to throw out a lot of ballots.
似乎没有争议认为所有选票上的选民签名是合法的。我想在你们所有人想废弃大量选票之前，我必须先听听那个。
The complaint is dismissed, 3 to 2. Dreams of the perfect Republican Christmas gift melt away. I can't say for sure, but in talking to reporters, election board members, activists, it seems that no one in North Carolina was able to find a single case of true voter fraud, where someone deliberately impersonates someone else, casts a ballot in their name, real fraud, except possibly one case. One. And that one comes out in a very strange twist during this same hearing, just not where the Republicans were looking. One of the board members starts asking McCrae, their incumbent Republican soil and water supervisor, about whether his side had committed voter fraud.
投诉被以3比2驳回。完美的共和党圣诞礼物的梦想融化了。我不敢肯定，但在与记者、选举委员会成员、活动人士交谈后，似乎北卡罗来纳州没有人能找到哪怕一个真正的选民欺诈案例，即某人故意冒充他人，以他们的名义投票，真正的欺诈，除了可能的一起案件。一起。而那一起在同一场听证会上以非常奇怪的转折曝光了，只是不是共和党人寻找的地方。委员会的一名成员开始询问麦克雷，他们现任的共和党土壤和水资源主管，他的这一方是否犯了选民欺诈。
So you keep saying GOTV, does that mean--
所以你一直说GOTV，那是什么意思——
Get out the vote. Get out the vote.
“动员投票”。动员投票。
You get paper.
你拿到纸。
Get out the vote.
动员投票。
And what exactly was it that she got paid to do?
她到底拿钱做了什么？
Here's what tumbles out of McCrae under the board's questioning. He had some people working for him, getting out the vote-- volunteers, McCrae calls them. The volunteers, though, were allegedly getting paid for each ballot they turned in. That is illegal. One of the voters who signed an affidavit said that Get Out the Vote workers came by and had her family request absentee ballots. But then they never received their absentee ballots in the mail like they were supposed to. Then, when the family went to vote on election day, they were told they'd already voted. In essence, McCrae's getting accused of paying people to obtain absentee ballots, fill them out, and cast their votes on someone else's behalf. That, for sure, is illegal. McCrae says he didn't do anything wrong.
这就是麦克雷在委员会盘问下吐露的内容。他有一些人为他工作，动员投票——麦克雷称他们为志愿者。然而，这些志愿者据称是每交出一张选票就能得到报酬。这是违法的。一名签署宣誓书的选民说，“动员投票”的工作人员来过，并让她家人申请了缺席选票。但后来他们从未像预期的那样在邮寄中收到缺席选票。然后，当这家人在选举日去投票时，他们被告知他们已经投过票了。本质上，麦克雷被指控花钱雇人获取缺席选票、填写并代表他人投票。那，绝对是违法的。麦克雷说他没做错什么。
An election board member then calls for further criminal investigation, what appears to be Republican voter fraud.
一名选举委员会成员随后呼吁进行进一步的刑事调查，这看起来像是共和党选民欺诈。
I will be making a motion, that any and all information that this board has in its possession shall be forwarded to the United States Attorney for the Eastern District of North Carolina.
我将动议，本委员会拥有的所有信息应转发给美国北卡罗来纳州东区检察官。
The attorney could choose to keep looking into Horace as well, but the focus of the investigation seems to be what McCrae has just revealed. Two days later, the governor of North Carolina concedes the race to the Democrats. There are just no votes left to recount, no more fraud left to look into.
检察官也可以选择继续调查霍勒斯，但调查的焦点似乎是麦克雷刚刚揭露的内容。两天后，北卡罗来纳州州长承认输给了民主党人。没有选票可以重新计票，没有更多的欺诈可以调查。
Dallas Woodhouse, the Republican fraud hunter, says there is still systemic voter fraud out there, stuff that's not being caught. And that is going to continue until the voting system itself changes. Right now, Dallas would say there are too many opportunities for voter fraud, too many ways that people could pretend to be someone else. Right now, you show up to vote with no ID, they let you vote. You show up at the wrong precinct, they let you vote.
共和党欺诈调查员达拉斯·伍德豪斯说，外面仍然存在系统性的选民欺诈，那些还没被抓住的东西。在投票系统本身改变之前，这种情况将会持续。现在，达拉斯会说，有太多的机会进行选民欺诈，太多人可以假装成别人。现在，你没有任何证件去投票，他们让你投。你在错误的选区出现，他们让你投。
Our side does think the voters have some responsibilities. And the best example is showing up to the right place to vote on election day. I do think that's a fair statement.
我们这一方确实认为选民有一些责任。最好的例子就是在选举日去正确的地点投票。我认为这是一个公平的陈述。
I think that is the exact thing that Democrats will point to saying, that disenfranchises our people because our people--
我认为这正是民主党人会指出的，称那剥夺了我们的人民，因为我们的人民——
How does it disenfranchise their people?
它怎么剥夺了他们的人民？
Because their people--
因为他们的人民——
See, they have such a negative, horrible, demeaning view of their own people, that they can't show up at the right place to vote.
瞧，他们对他们自己的人民有一种如此消极、可怕、贬低的态度，以至于他们不能去正确的地点投票。
The two parties have very different ideas about how we should vote. To generalize, Democrats think it should be as easy as possible. Republicans don't. Conveniently, each of these positions ends up helping their side at the polls. Tougher voter requirements tend to disproportionately discourage minority voters. That traditionally helps Republicans. Higher voter turnout of minority voters usually helps the Democrats. Dallas, a passionate partisan, will keep arguing and keep looking for fraud, though he keeps losing these fights.
两党对我们应该如何投票有截然不同的想法。概括地说，民主党人认为应该尽可能简单。共和党人不这么认为。方便的是，这些立场中的每一个最终都帮助了他们这一方在投票站获胜。更严格的投票要求往往会不成比例地阻碍少数族裔选民。这传统上帮助共和党人。少数族裔选民的更高投票率通常帮助民主党人。达拉斯，一个热情的党派人士，将继续争论并继续寻找欺诈，尽管他一直在输掉这些战斗。
The North Carolina State Board of Elections tracked 57 voter fraud complaints this year and dismissed the vast majority of them. For those searching for voter fraud, it's like they waited all election year, opened up their presents Christmas morning, and there was nothing inside.
北卡罗来纳州选举委员会今年追踪了57起选民欺诈投诉，驳回了其中的绝大多数。对于那些寻找选民欺诈的人来说，就像他们等了整个选举年，圣诞早晨打开礼物，里面却空空如也。
Zoe Chace is one of the producers of our show.
佐伊·蔡斯是我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC - "JUST WHAT I WANTED FOR CHRISTMAS" BY BING CROSBY"]
[音乐 - 平·克劳斯贝的《恰如我愿的圣诞节》]
Well, our program was produced today by Stephanie Foo, our production staff-- Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Miki Meeke, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Research help today from Christopher [? Sotala, ?] music help from Damien Grave.
好了，我们的节目今天由斯蒂芬妮·富制作，我们的制作团队——苏珊·伯顿、佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德拉明、凯伦·达芬、伊曼纽尔·佐齐、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、大卫·克斯滕鲍姆、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩、马特·蒂尔尼和南希·厄普代克。今天的研究帮助来自克里斯托弗 [？索塔拉，？]，音乐帮助来自达米安·格雷夫。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, great around the office, but whenever I try to talk to him about my personal issues, he sticks his fingers in his ears and he says--
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）传送给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，在办公室里他很棒，但每当我想和他谈论我的个人问题时，他就把手指塞进耳朵里说——
(SINGING) La la la la la la la la la la.
(唱歌) 啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回《美国生活》的更多故事。
[MUSIC - "JUST WHAT I WANTED FOR CHRISTMAS" BY BING CROSBY"]
[音乐 - 平·克劳斯贝的《恰如我愿的圣诞节》]